[Music]
this week on
forward philanthropy has not solved a
real problem in a long time there you
can count on one hand how many times
traditional philanthropy which means you
giving money to charity has actually
solved a problem now I don't mean a
symptom I don't mean it's done good yeah
we people are hungry and we feed them
that's a symptom you're treating the
symptom but I mean cure has philanthropy
ever cured hunger absolutely not the
average corporate Corporation gives 1%
of their profits to charity a year which
is a lot don't get me wrong like fact
they're getting anything is is fantastic
but it's not fundamental to anything
they do what this is a way to do is for
a corporate to get involved with helping
that nonprofit you love uh and care
[Music]
about it is my pleasure to welcome back
to the podcast the man my former co-host
and former campaign manager you know him
as big coat guy Zach grman is back with
us we're back man hi everybody so Zach
the thing on everyone's mind is where
have you been what have you been up to
now I know the answers to these
questions uh but where have you been and
what have you been doing so I guess you
have to lead with this because it's
priority in life but I got
married you know Zach is a newly wed
does he still have that newly glow got
the glow got a ring I would say the
biggest change in getting married is um
uh wearing a ring as a guy never done
that so that's a bit of takes a bit of
getting used to and still does and
trying not to fiddle with it and then
the other one is
introducing Carly as my wife to people
you know mean like very oh this is my
hey this is my wife whoa haven't you
know like saying that out loud adult is
a pretty it's a bit of a shock and I
imagine most people who have been
married like have felt it especially we
did it later in life um but yeah man got
married we got married in Manchester
Vermont where Carly Carly's essentially
from she's from the town next door and
her parents live in Manchester now so uh
was gorgeous we had uh it rained it
downpour for about 10 minutes the whole
weekend and it was literally during the
ceremony just during y I was
there uh Andrew was there standing up
next to me it was fun it was really fun
it was a wonderful weekend um I
do he recommends getting married for I
recommend getting married I recommend
doing a big party don't recommend
spending a ton of money on it I mean he
recommends marrying the love of your
life and having a big party having a big
party it is fun to have a lot of love in
the room it's stressful and it's
expensive so I don't there's probably
ways we could have done less stress less
money um but we had a blast we really
did whatever man the memories last
forever the credit card bill will
eventually go away eventually go away
what's that book die with zero did you
have him on I of course I had it's a
Memory dividend if you listen deep cut
of this podcast listeners memory
dividend he'll pay dividends some and
this and the wedding was a Yang 2020
reunion there were dozens of us there uh
and that was a blast in itself fun we
had Germaine was there I had seen
Germaine really since the campaign so we
got a big Germaine Johnson bear hug uh
he and his wife were there it was fun it
was really fun we had a big campaign
Crew The Campaign Stafford stayed in a
house on site which was kind of fun and
it of course is where they held the late
night multiple times so and that's where
Yang
2024 was born
con we did talk about your political
future that's that's part for the course
C I mean you get is he going to run
again I get a bunch of Yang alums in oh
yeah only one person knows and you're
looking at him yeah that's true now uh
now wedding planning is a lot and um but
obviously that isn't all you've been up
to so to frame this a little bit uh
before Zach managed my presidential
campaign he started a nonprofit called
sued up for underprivileged kids it
helps get kids exposure to professionals
and get a sense of what's out there so
they have aspirations that are more uh
direct and immediate than uh let's say
becoming a pro athlete or Entertainer
which is highly visible to these kids
and after starting suit up uh you
learned something about a problem that
now we're trying to solve yeah I I'm
happy to be here because um I got
something we working on I think you all
may find interesting a couple you may
find very interesting um depending on
the causes and Charities you support but
it's something we've never we've only
like Loosely unpacked and I I think it's
good to unpack is basically what's
broken about our nonprofit and
philanthropic world World um cuz Andrew
and I spent we've both spent a lot of
time in there and it affects all of us
cuz everybody gives um the vast majority
of um and don't we just kind of
assume these things about giving that
are really wrong and so um I grew up
Andrew I um I've always been interested
in this my my dad was an engineer but my
mom was a teacher so I was always
interested in like for-profits and
nonprofits kind of like public and
private intersecting um
I was a public policy major in college
um and then actually when I graduated I
had two job offers one was to do Wall
Street which I ended up doing um but the
other was Teach for America to go teach
I got a job offer to do teach special
needs kids in post Katrina New Orleans
so like front line save the world like
my mom what year was that that was
2010 when I I graduated in 2010 so I
remember like look on Duke's campus like
walking around being like I hated this
decision I can go make money and get out
of side student loan so like get out of
debt and make money but not like love my
impact or I could go literally a version
of saving the world but I would I was
looking at like not getting out of debt
for decades you're making nothing in a
really tough area in New Orleans um and
I imagine for those of you listening
it's probably a decision a version of a
decision you've had in your own life
where I can go like doing well and doing
good are kind of separate like you can
do one or the others to do both um and I
know you've had that when you you sold
your company you're like now I can do
good you know or I guess you tried with
your
charity um but yeah I started a
nonprofit that Iran for uh six and a
half years or so so uh we had parallel
Journeys though I started Venture for
America and worked there full-time
whereas you somehow managed to start a
Million Dollar Plus nonprofit uh while
holding another day job which is pretty
stunning because it certainly took
everything I had to get Venture for
America to that level and I didn't have
a demanding job I was balancing so when
you hit Wall Street um you actually
found the most wholesome thing a wall
streer could do which is you worked in
the philanthropy practice which is
advising wealthy people how to give
their money away and so you're
interfaced with a bunch of nonprofits
and in so doing you kind of learn the
limits of the space which is one thing I
learned uh by running a nonprofit oh
yeah and one of the things I say to
folks when I'm thinking big uh is look
you're talking about uh now 2425
trillion economy the biggest nonprofits
in the world operate at uh maybe a
billion dollar level and that would be
highly highly unusual like the vast
majority of nonprofits are operating at
the0 to10 million range let's say and so
if you're trying to reformat a 242 25
trillion economy me there is no way to
do so from the nonprofit sector uh the
only way to do so would be to get a hold
of the federal government which is why I
ran for president to try and do that um
but you also Drew similar conclusions
based upon advising all these
philanthropists yeah so here's the gig
so I'm started I started in this like
corporate it was a training program and
I ended up in corporate
strategy and there were a couple thing I
started volunteering to get my save the
world kick I joined this school board
down in uh near Coney Island like middle
school kids lower income area and we go
I'm at like the board meeting we had
done like our annual survey of the kids
and we ask them hey what do you want to
be when you grow up and they're all like
the answers I got were pop star and an
athlete essentially um it was like a
large majority it wasn't doctor teacher
lawyer some of the basics or
entrepreneur Etc it was kind of what
they knew and here I was like 23y old
kid like working on Wall Street college
grad like I didn't know what I wanted to
do when I grew up and these kids didn't
even know what they could be didn't even
know their options it was somewhat
heartbreaking and also really jarring um
and then the second thing was that in
the corporate world where we sucked at
philanthropy we sucked at our I called
our daily volunteer days we would go
like build poorly constructed houses
imagine a bunch of like white collar
like data nerds painting crap painting
stuff that had to be repainted after you
left we scra we scraped Barnacles off
the side of the Intrepid in the middle
of August which is the The Boat Museum
on the Hudson here was awful it's a
disaster so started suit up on the side
basically like I can run ubs's like my
team's volunteer day and we brought
basically brought my my team into to our
my school in Coney Island um and we did
like a shark tank light like a one-day
business competition we said to the kids
you're CEO of Nike today you get to
solve a real problem for that company so
you had to design a new shoe and Pitch
it and uh there's a finance component
and a marketing component winning team
get real money turned out the kids loved
it they learned all the things they
could be they learned about certain
career options they got really natural
mentors and UBS loved it because was way
better than picking up trash turns out
Pimco called me a couple weeks later
like Word of Mouth got out next thing I
know I have a business on my handline of
social Enterprise um and that's how I
got into what was called Phil like
client philanthropy advisory at UBS
because I was like should I quit my job
and run this nonprofit still not I pay
that well um but I love it it's it needs
to exist and my boss I was really
fortunate at the time my boss said hey
we have a philanthropy team I don't know
anything about it but and now report to
me based on our fifth reorg this year
like it's kind of a thing we do on Wall
Street uh why don't you check it out so
I ended up running our client
philanthropy advisory team which meant
that I helped really wealthy people give
money to charity I was 25 years old and
you had to have a $100 million liquid to
get a meeting with me which is an insane
statement um yeah you're talking about
billionaires that's insane I'm 25 and my
I'm actually this was the craziest part
and this is what we're talking about I'm
actually qualified to do this because I
had actually got my hands dirty in this
space and I learned a lot more than some
of these billionaire you knew you knew a
lot more than the average philanth which
was crazy um actually deliver results on
and well that's what I learned is that
philanthropy I'm going to say this
philanthropy has not solved a real
problem in a long time there you can
count on one hand how many times
traditional philanthropy which means you
giving money to charity has actually
solved a problem now I don't mean a
symptom I don't mean it's done good yeah
we people are hungry and we feed them
that's a symptom you're treating the
symptom but I mean cure has philanth
ever cured hunger absolutely not um and
you could go down the list the big two
that philanthropy has actually solved I
want to give them their flowers where do
malaria um Distributing malaria vaccines
I'll give credit to The Gates Foundation
before Ebola is that 2017 2018 that
range uh malaria was legitimately on a
very very clear path to be white wiped
off the planet so malaria no more and a
couple great organizations really really
strong um like vaccine distribution
essentially and vaccines in general uh
philanthropy dollars have funded a lot
of that so give their flowers there and
then the second one is our national 911
Network we used to have an emergency
hotline um system that was based on
States so Connecticut had one Vermont
had one but if you crossed over state
borders and you're a Connecticut
resident you get injured in Vermont it
was kind of a hot mess so private family
foundations actually got together and
made our national 911 Network and so
private and that's how it should work it
doesn't without should work is donors
private donors and wealthy families
invest in a kind of a risky social
Enterprise that's supposed to help
people and then if it works government
can step in and kind of systemize it and
scale it other than that guys most
things don't work think of any problem
you think of or have in this country and
has not been solved by charity that does
not stop us from donating and from
nonprofits to keep asking you for
money this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now yeah yeah the nonprofits do good
work I mean this is my experience
adventure for America really proud of
everything we did um but one reason I
ran for president was that I actually
started Venture for America because I
wanted to create a functional economy uh
yeah which sounds like I should start a
nonprofit like I want to help people
yeah and uh and so and I determined that
in order to start a functional economy
you would need to change a lot of things
that the a nonprofit never will be able
to Yes uh and so you need to have a
functional government and so I'm still
on the functional government train I
believe it's the highest leverage thing
we can do even though it's very
difficult and arduous uh um but it's the
only genuine answer and uh one of the
things I suggest to People by the way a
lot of philanthropists are wising up to
this yeah is like look let's say you're
going to pump millions of dollars into
education uh like you know what's not
going to change is our education all
outcomes unless you actually had a
better educational system how do you get
a better educational system there's
similar with climate change it's like
hey you're going to pump millions of
dollars into climate change you know
what would help with that like a
government that was doing various things
so this so this becomes the highest
leverage move you can make even though
again like people and a lot of people
it's like oh politics want to stay away
it's like look I get it I hate politics
too but if we're going to try and solve
the biggest problems
meaningfully that's how someone like me
winds up running for president that's
how someone like me winds up starting
the forward party uh and and so we're
trying to make the good things happen
now you have taken a different Tac which
is something that I a th% endorse and
support and am uh an investor in and a
board member of and very helpful but you
identified a problem and then started a
benevolent B Corp to try and solve that
problem and create a win-win win so what
is the problem and then what the heck is
Samar so let me back back a one step and
that
essentially my takeaways both before I
joined the campaign then during the
campaign and even now in starting smity
is that doing good by the numbers and
also my personal experience it's not in
great shape and don't get me wrong
there's amazing nonprofit organizations
that that do fantastic work and I want
to be very we got to be very clear here
we're not talking about if if you're a
nonprofit executive listening to this
you're like wait my organization does
incredible work screw you Zach you don't
know what you're talking about that's
not what I'm talking about what I'm
talking about is the institution and its
systems um and the numbers are the
proves in the pudding um household
giving is down um and has been declining
now some of that's economy related but
percentage of households as a whole
giving is going down as well amount of
Americans volunteering massively
declining we ALS
say we want You' asked somebody do you
want to volunteer this year are you
going to volunteer this year the answer
is yes Almost 100% of people say yes I'm
going to volunteer that's like are you
an question um we all say yes no
I'm not no I'm not a jerk yes I'm going
to volunteer the reality is one in four
people will volunteer this year um and
that's it's kind of the the same thing
you see with companies we say we're
doing awesome things but the reality is
we got to make money well well part of
the reason why so few people will
actually volunteer is that you're not
sure your time's going to be uh well
show up and a lot of these organs be
like narf you
know no one's fault but uh you know just
I mean I I actually volunteered for a
nonprofit as a 20-some year old and they
had me do something really you know like
I literally um uh stuffed envelopes and
then sealed the envelopes I like ran out
of saliva if you talk to nonprofit they
will not if you really get them in an
honest environment they're like most of
the time we don't need volunteers unless
some organizations like suit up like
they actually set up to to utilize
utilize volunteers but most are not um
and that's so the problem of looking at
like on the macro level is that
philanthropy does what I call a Feelgood
model and and what I mean by that is
that if you're wealthy or if you're a
big company if you have resources
nonprofits will come to you and say look
at these Starving Children look at this
horrible problem aren't you not a jerk
and you have money can't you help us and
don't get me wrong that does work some
way in terms of getting resources to
places um but it's not it treats a
symptom it doesn't treat the Cure and so
like taking a big step back y'all like
how do we look at this system like how
do we get how do we get beyond the
Feelgood um the average corporate
Corporation gives 1% of their profits to
charity a year which is a lot don't get
me wrong like they're the fact they're
getting anything is is fantastic but
it's not fundamental to anything they do
and the reality is Coca-Cola would give
more to charity more than
1% if it helped them sell more cocaa or
if it solved a problem or if it solved a
problem for them that was helping them
themselves um you know sell more coke
and that's not that's what it's
fundamentally set up to do so what I
what I'm trying to create here is a
shift from the Feelgood model to an
incentives model an efficacy model and
yeah it's a good way to put it as well
where
Coca-Cola has more incentive to support
great causes now that's tricky and if
you talk to folks that
work in the nonprofit industry there's a
certain Purity that they value where
it's like we are here to help and that's
it we don't care about making money we
care about doing good that is true that
is a good thing that said there's a way
to align these incentives especially if
you have government that's ineffective
Coca-Cola does care about education the
employees of that company and Executives
most most of the time actually care
about living in a great world and having
great schools for kids and other kids to
go to so how do you align these
incentives um so that's Rel land with
Samari he's like
what can there be for-profit incentives
at company to help nonprofit goals and
Ambitions and social causes yeah you get
that 1% up to uh 1.5 2% 3% it's a game
changer we talking Market talking about
billions of dollars yes so how do you do
this and then like really think about is
like okay what does Habitat for Humanity
as a example nonprofit what do they have
to offer
Coca-Cola in terms of Val let's use
another one man let's use Humanity
forward yeah what does Humanity forward
have to add value to Delta or various
Industries various companies um in a
incentive aligned way and where we've
landed is what we found and what we
found is what do Charities have they
have a lot of supporters um and in many
ways they have passionate supporters
they have the ability to cut through the
noise differently so where Samar is
right now it's a a version of a market
research company um so what we're doing
is we're helping nonprofits raise money
by polling their supporters um so how it
works right now if you're a
nonprofit and uh you have what's called
you have your email list you have your
social media followers you have your
volunteer events etc etc instead of
asking them for money like you normally
do or telling them about your awesome
work would you also right um we give you
a custom email or custom survey link
that you can send and share with all
your supporters and for every person who
completes that survey the nonprofit
unlocks a donation uh donations vary
usually on average one to five bucks and
as a nonprofit you keep the data you can
we are essentially like an outsourced
donor research supporter research
service you get all this data cuz it's
yours um and you also get the money for
it and then the data is secure it's
Anonymous and what we are as as a market
research firm we package all up
anonymously and put together market
research reports that your deltas and
coca-colas and Amazon and JD Powers Etc
are interested in paying for and we
share the profits of course with
nonprofits and if you think about this
the dream
is your Coca-Cola you're spending $10
million on Market Research every year
can you spend 5 million on that with
Samar it's the same exact market
research but a chunk of it is actually
going to Charities so trying to find
that win-win so it's a nice win if
you're a nonprofit We have some
nonprofits making, bucks a month or so
just to send out surveys that many of
them want to or should be doing anyways
so it's um it's it's early now we're
just starting we're onboarding our first
like 100 to 200
nonprofits but we're pretty excited
because we feel like this is the first
Runway or like entry into aligning the
incentives of the for-profit and
nonprofit
world
imagine running for president and
wanting to share what you experienced in
a way that's entertaining edifying and
maybe even a little bit scary that's the
last election out in book stores now a
novel about an independent presidential
candidate a journalist with a massive
story and what the heck could be our
nextlast election check it out at
andrewyang.com
[Music]
well I I love it because it's a
win-win-win all the way around uh if
you're a nonprofit you want to know more
about your donors in community anyway uh
and so you send the survey plus you get
paid and if you are a supporter you say
wait a minute uh if I fill out the
survey my nonprofit benefits uh I mean
that that's pretty St straightforward
and direct and easy and if you're the
company um I'm paying for Intel if I can
actually help a nonprofit maybe get some
glow for that um then bully for me uh
how much money is spent on Market
Research as an activity it is now this
is everything but it's a multi-
multi-billion dollar industry um now
that includes like there's a couple
there's lots of different types of
market research there's your uh your
Neon reports where like the the boxes
people use for TV ratings is a version
of market research there's your own
qualitative and quantitative data like
if you're CVS and you're tracking you
know the the self checkout kiosk so you
you get the credit card info and what
people are buying there's that type of
market research um but there are still
billions billions of dollars going into
just straight up surveys and it's tough
if you think about um a lot of surveys
right now are just people taking Sur
surveys for money um and so what we're
flipping the model is we're letting
nonprofits ask their supporters to take
surveys for donations to the cause and
so the the ideally it's a win-win win so
the pitch to the consumer I was a little
concerned about this but if you're a
nonprofit supporter I was like are you
going to be turned off by a random JD
Power survey or a survey about running
shoes or credit card spending Etc the
reality is we're all people we get asked
those questions all the time we trust
our charity to know it's anonymous
and it's we actually had a lot of
positive feedback because it's better to
be asked to fill out a survey than it is
to give money all the time and a lot of
people are actually willing to share
with their friends if you love your
cause I have friends that are on the
suitup team and suitup board they're
like hey like suitup if you take this
survey we get money to suit up like
please take this put it on their
Instagram story Etc so a good pitch to
supporters the pitch to nonprofits is
hey you get paid to send an email to
send a survey link uh you maybe should
be sending this doing survey you get you
you get info and you get money um at a
pretty really low lift and it's almost
like a recurring Revenue stream for
nonprofits very similar what Amon slow
month s that surve seriously and that's
what happened and I'm nonprofits that
put in their newsletter and their email
signatures Etc and their social you know
social media handles Etc and then the
pitch the company's the best one it's
like hey I can get you better data
because it's real people that we verify
with real organizations and there's a
trust relationship there that it doesn't
normally exist you verify it's real
person uh and you can get it essentially
for cheaper because the nonprofits are
getting it's found money to them right
so it's for the quality of data it's a
better cost to the company too so it it
really we believe and we're finding it's
a win for everybody just right now it's
new right this is what we're doing we're
talking a little bit couple podcasts and
a couple conferences to get the word out
to our first 100 200 nonprofits put out
our first couple Flagship reports and
seeing what happens what's fun is you
you work with really small nonprofits
you might have modest lists for whom
getting 500 bucks or a th000 bucks a
month might be actually pretty
meaningful yeah I I'd love the the range
is like we have a couple nonprofits with
like a thousand people on their email
list or social followings to certain
organizations with a million um and it
works for either right there's certain
benefits to both um if you're a
multi-million person you know nonprofit
or millions of supporters getting that
information is valuable in itself right
the money is is what it is and that's
great but um getting that info and
understanding it um almost like I said
earlier like a outsourced donor research
arm as opposed to your smaller
nonprofits actually a good way to grow
your email list because you have you
know it's called a couple hundred diard
supporters they takes a survey and share
it with their friends so um and some of
these causes and you know these causes
if you're listening where literally
every dollar somewhat matters is
literally going to help
somebody
this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big Tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and you're
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's ex s vpn.com yangang and you can
get an extra 3 months free
expressvpn.com
yangang and and the vision actually
grows uh in the sense that so this is
one way you've discovered to potentially
align corporate incentives with helping
nonprofits yeah um but there are other
ways that we can line those incentives
up too right yeah I I hope like what's
what's like if everything goes ideally
what does Samar become so the ultimate
dream of this is can we start
incentivizing
people to do more good and and I say do
more
good more broader than that than that
maybe seems where do more good is not
just hang out and volunteer and donate
to more Charities but um I'll give you
an example um I'm a Buffalo Bills fan so
last year when Demar Hamlin passed out
on you know collapsed on the football
field it was it was shocking obviously
as as a fan even more shocking um and to
me there was this national moment that I
wish we had capitalized more on where
the awareness of CPR training and um
like AED like the like machines being
more publicly accessible and taking CPR
courses was so freaking there that any
company would have wanted to capitalize
on it in a Wholesome Way that didn't
feel cringeworthy so be able to say hey
anyone that can take a CPR training
right
now Coca-Cola is going to pay for that
training right now and we can verify it
verify that you took the course and
unlock a donation to XYZ charity of your
choice so being able to build like kind
of a a bigger do good army um and
incentivize folks to do good in ways
that are a little less traditional uh
that's kind of the dream and in order to
do that you have to make it easy and
accessible for companies to what's
called sponsor Charities right and
that's tough they I joke like nonprofits
speak different language like my schools
in Harlem where I work with suitup in in
New York City they speak a different
language than Goldman Sachs speaks and
they're 40 blocks away dude I'm gonna
I'm going to lay a deep cut on you right
now yeah it's crazy um but in a way what
you're trying to do is build an earlier
version of digital social credits and
the the lowest hanging fruit activity is
to do something that companies already
pay for in the form of filling out a
survey but it could be taking that CPR
class eventually it could be tutoring
the underprivileged kid it could be
helping your neighbor yes and we're
trying to create that Marketplace and
this is uh the the earliest Nexus I
think I mean if there's a world where
hey you volunteer to help your neighbor
and you earned 100 points and you could
convince Chipotle that those 100 points
are worth the free burrito right I think
that's a really remarkable way of doing
sort of a social credit model and here's
the other thing about that is I don't
love the government being the like judge
jury executioner of what a social credit
is worth so if there's a world where the
private Market can actually evaluate
that where it's nonprofits and
for-profits and people what right now
when they're putting money to work I
mean the return is just so uh hard to
measure and weird
if you knew that a human was actually
helping their neighbor tutoring that kid
cleaning theace whatever and you knew it
and then it was verifiable and then you
could have your brand Associated
anywhere near that I mean you'd be all
over it the problem right now is just
that you know it's like we rely upon
essentially the company to be like hey
we did this thing here's some photos
here's like us giv the check like da da
you know it's like and and now uh trust
is eroding to a point it's one reason
why this has such profound effects U
medium to long term is that you know who
people trust the most uh their friends
and family um nonprofits then are much
much also more trusted uh you know
corporates not so much uh anymore and so
what this is a way to do is for a
corporate to get involved with helping
that nonprofit you love uh and care
about eventually it's helping your
actual
friends family community I mean in in a
way that's undeniable because maybe it's
you doing it it's like hey I know I did
the thing so this is one of the Holy
Grails of all of um like branding and
brand associations and what's
interesting is that the brands are uh
are are trying to respond in various
ways to the erosion of trust so they're
investing in their own self-generated
content they're like look guys like you
know like us having a Snappy ad really
is not the answer answer anymore people
see through that so you know let's
try to do something real and this is an
opportunity for the company to do
something real starting with sponsoring
that nonprofits uh survey stuff uh you
know but but but that but that's you
know I mean that that's the first stop
and then hopefully it we create a whole
chain of stops so if there is someone
who uh let's say runs a nonprofit or
volunteers at a nonprofit or there's
even someone listening to this who uh
buys Market intelligence or works for a
company's marketing arm how can they get
in touch with you and Samar so I would
the best place to go I'd go to sear.com
nonprofits that's s m a RIT Ty
y.com nonprofits that's if you're a
nonprofit and you want to start
earning actual donations for sending
Yeezy surveys you can sign up right
there it's great there's a little video
explains most the information he needs
on there and we'll reach out to you um
and then you can also email us it's
hello.com pretty basic and you know like
just to add on to what you said Andrew I
want to be clear on this it's
that if there's anything I learned
particularly from my time running suitup
and and at UBS is that doing good and
giving money to charity in particular
it's really hard it is a to do it
effectively anyone can write a check but
to do it effectively is a massive
Challenge and we joke at the corporate
level we see like inre and I we've heard
this multiple times a CEO will say hey
we give a million dollars a charity and
then we spend another million dollars
trying to tell everybody about it and
making sure that like people know we're
doing it um it's difficult to be
effective and true and authentic in this
space and I spent time and probably one
of the reasons I really got into this is
I met with billionaires all P like with
seemingly infinity money focused on a
cause and they weren't able to solve
anything nope um we did a at UBS we did
an event called our autism Innovation
roundt table and we brought together
some of the wealthiest people on the
planet with kids on the Spectrum so you
had like you 10 to 20 billionaires in
the room all passionate about the same
topic and we still aren't really able to
do much um there's a lot of hurdles and
I've you know had to give talks on this
Etc but it's Charity's hard uh measuring
social impact is hard these are CH some
of these problems are are human level
problems right so um but if we have a
vehicle where it's just a little bit of
incentive uh lined up between the people
making the money and the people giving
it away I feel like that's a big win so
yeah sam.com nonprofits the best place
to go hello ats.com if you want to email
us and look I'm a big believer in
putting yourself out there trying
failing seeing what happens the worst
thing that's going to happen right now
is we're going to have a bunch of
nonprofits get some money for sending
some surveys the best thing that's going
to happen is you're going to have CCA
writing million dollar checks to an
organization and a vast majority of
that's going to go to charity um and
they're going to increase how much they
spend and it won't just be Coca-Cola so
that's pretty cool yeah man the best
case scenario is moving us a step closer
to a human- centered economy uh and I I
love that you've tackled it in this way
where we're not waiting for let's say
government to get it together uh
but you know like find corporates for
whom it makes sense find nonprofits find
nonprofit supporters for whom it makes
sense put them together build an awesome
business uh hopefully improve a lot of
lives uh and um really pump to be able
to be helpful to you on this leg of your
journey uh people who are close to the
campaign know that you the reason why
Yang 2020 became a thing check out
Zach's book Longshot on the on the
campaign rting stuff
oh fun my father-in-law read it and or
not my father sorry my brother's
father-in-law sorry let me rephrase that
my brother's father-in-law pulled me
pulled me aside at the wedding I was
like I read your book and I actually
liked it and he's the kind of guy
that'll tell you if he hates something
so that's best compliment I got so
ringing endorsement from my brother's
father-in-law for whatever that's worth
yeah but um but our campaign was a leg
in your journey uh and the guy's a limit
for you Zach in terms of the good you
can do in the world anyone who's listen
to this story is like well Zach
definitely is sincere about doing good
because he's been at it for uh years and
years and years and that's why you
managed Yang 2020 is you said look uh
this is an opportunity to maybe move us
in a better Direction so with Samar my
friend and we'll be there with you every
step of the way thanks man it's a
privilege to be on hope you all can find
it useful and we'll I'll come back when
we've either hopefully when we we've uh
we're rocking and rolling man as a
household name oh yeah know this hey
guys help Zack and samity rock and roll
so that when he returns to the podcast
it'll beared one of those um Shark Tank
typ Happy Endings you know what I mean
like he came
to I got something new now
no awesome
man